[Music]
juror from the Greek word for circle
gyros or if you're hungry Lido's
describes a spiraling motion or
formation and to earth it means a
rotating ocean current there are five
ocean gyres but only one deserves to be
truly trash-talked the North Pacific
Gyre which thanks to the hand of humans
is home to the Great Pacific Garbage
Patch in it there's potentially millions
of square miles of trash over 20,000
tons mostly plastic it was discovered
back in 1997 by a great man explorer
slash surfer Charles Moore who like in
the gyre to a bowl of plastic soup and a
toilet that doesn't flush hmm there is a
significant trash pile up in other gyres
just in case they felt left out garbage
stays in them for years even decades
swirling aimlessly and recently
researchers studying the pacific plastic
archipelago discovered that debris from
the 2011 earthquake and tsunami in japan
has also begun to collect in it but
don't book your tickets to trash island
just yet studies show that the patch
isn't solid trash doesn't always stay on
the surface of the sea it disperses
sinks and breaks down slowly
remember Einstein plastic doesn't
biodegrade it takes about a thousand
years for it to degrade at all
ie around the same time at the rapture
and all that plastic in the ocean
doesn't just mean pollutants in the
ocean it means pollutants in the fish
that eat the plastic and pollutants in
the humans who eat the fish who eat the
plastic to say nothing of the whales
birds turtles and mermen it's also
breaking off in large chunks and washing
up on coastlines where does it come from
you just kidding actually you are part
of the problem worldwide humans use over
a hundred and ten million tons of
Barbie's favorite fabric and right now
in the ocean there's an estimated a
hundred million tons of it but I recycle
you say good but only five percent of
plastics worldwide are ever recycled
much of the rest is giant without a
doubt the ocean is becoming our waste
bin and you thought you could just leave
it on the curb and forget about it
you